[Music]
[Applause]
thank
you thank you good evening I'm so glad
to see all of you tonight on the uh on
the way in somebody gave us a home movie
to scan
please uh treat this as aspirational
behavior and get in
touch um you know this this uh event is
built on generosity I I I must thank
long now the internet archive our
longtime uh partner in so many ways the
filecoin foundation for the
decentralized web which has made the
amazing scans you're going to see
tonight possible and of course the uh uh
the the gifted um Experts of pringer
archives and pringer Library who have
worked very hard to make all of this
possible so you know that this show is
mostly silent it's 73 minutes 11 minutes
of sound 61 minutes of silence your job
is to fill those 61 minutes with
identifications with uh uh reactions
with uh disputes with your your
neighbors or others please make some
noise every show is different um I'm
grateful to all of you for your uh
support especially those of you who have
supported the library and archives in
many ways and uh I hope you like the
show thank you so
[Applause]
much
right
thank you Brian
Boyce good evening the San Francisco
television Center presents see yourself
tonight on this program you have a
chance to be filmed here on Market
Street at 11: in the morning and then in
the evening see yourself on the
television receip if you haven't yet
caught your set we invite you to visit
the San Francisco television Center and
see the nationally advertised sets which
are being demonstrated there each
evening on this program the particip
ipants discuss the headlines of the day
and also in addition to seeing
themselves tonight have a chance to see
the show at the embassy theater because
they'll each receive two passs showing
now Hollow Triumph and this time for
Keeps and here is today's
headline now we're going to turn to the
audience here CU we have someone in the
how about this young man here A Soldier
come on over
Soldier glad to see you here we you
stand right in here thank
what's your name Samy blis and where you
from Mr Chicago Chicago how does this
weather compare with Chicago well that's
much called in Chicago now well uh are
you dressed for oh yeah I'm dressed but
I nice over I mean they always say you
know The Californians are cold when it
gets cold because uh they don't dress
warmly well this is my first trip to
California I would know about how long
you been
yesterday yesterday where' you come from
Chicago oh you
and uh how was it snowing there well not
when I left you saw this headline in the
call this afternoon have you ever been
to Los Ang no sir that's where I want to
go you want to go there today oh I can't
go there the base I see I mean would you
like to go today with about 6 to 12 in
of
snow to my surprise to doar that uh tell
me something do you subscribe to the
theory that many people have that uh
there is a gradual change in the weather
all over the country
how myself
like in Chicago we have lot of
snowstorms but now we don't get them in
our summers we usually are over 100° now
we don't even get that much than so lot
so do here are your passes to the you
have aish that sir well we like you
while you're here if you have a chance
to drop into the San Francisco
television Center and see the RCA
eyewitness the Hoffman the filco and the
many other sets that are being
demonstrated there thanks a lot your
passes hope you enjoyed the
show
the
P portals at the present we're in
Portals at the
past no this is the
marina outside the marina no
Bridge
[Music]
I need an aviation expert to be in touch
about that so Henry was a friend he was
a very contemplative man he loved red
and he and he tried very hard in his um
semi in his professionally shot home
movies to put a little red in so how fun
finding
it
that's poor
Mason
[Music]
guante
this is the San Francisco segment of a
2hour film about traveling across the
country
how did hech up the
yeah the uh the film of the era Kodak
Chrome has a pastel look but not the
Reds yes it is 16
mm
right you can see from The Flash frames
that he's editing this in the
camera thank you
Megan today the California story of grow
is one of the exciting chapters in the
history of human progress because it is
primarily a story of people men women
children following a natural urge to
live in to work in to play in this
golden land a land where they can play
all year round where young champions are
developed earlier than anywhere else
because of a 12 months play at practice
cycle our climate here is as close to
perfect as it can be anywhere on Earth
and once here the newcomer would rather
be here than anywhere
else a man can work here in December
without needing an open were take his
Recreation every month of the year in
light
clothing here there are no half years
for Farmers no years of only summer
activities with winter idleness while
the land sleeps under a blanket of
snow yes people begin and support the
story of Northern and central California
with their enthusiasm for its truly
great climate and the ample room they
have found to live in it in new home
modern original and imaginative as the
challenge of the land itself a land of
Elbow Room where a man get his Destiny
to develop a new industry small or large
on land that he can afford to
buy he can build himself a 750,000 ton
Mountain of salt or level a mountain of
Earth to make room for a new
community where men can erect the
longest and highest single Span in the
world a mile long overwater steel
platform or usher in an age of
wing
yeah where the
rice
the uh the old NBC Studios later channel
44 now I think a tech
company
right the special mun Shopper shuttle is
extinct San Francisco possibly the most
Charming city in the United
Stateside the San Francisco Bay area is
getting a far more rapid transit system
in fact the most rapid and modern in the
world a 75m complex of Subway tunnel
elevated and surface tracks will link
San Francisco with Oakland Berkeley and
the East Bay suburbs the project has
been in the planning for over 10 years
actual Construction started in
1965 and the first passenger service is
expected in
1968 with the final link completed 3
years
[Music]
thereafter the tunnel under San
Francisco Bay will be the longest
underwater Rapid Transit Cube in the
world the reason for the more than 3/4
of a billion dollar expenditure for this
fast train service is that which impels
so many projects of today the population
explosion within 25 years the Bay Area
is expected to double its population
statisticians work it out that this
means a gain of over 400 new residents
and nearly 250 new vehicles every day
there seems to be no time to
lose
bring back the Egg
[Music]
card
right you have to put your bike in a
bag right we're looking at an 8mm film
shot and the first first few years of of
Bart at a time when there was such
incredible public enthusiasm it's in so
many home movies uh and this is um this
is a family's day kind of a long day I
think it's a long movie riding the
trains
par
my biggest thrill on Bart's opening day
was standing right behind the train
operator uh and looking at that uh
spedometer go up to 81 miles an hour I
didn't I was from the East Coast I
didn't think such things were possible
and and this operator is dressed in in
her Spacey her Star Trek like uh
uniform and
uh it was September 11
1972 opening of Bart this is a year
later puts her foot
up
and here's a family visiting from down
south and this is one of my favorite
downtown hope home movies it just
captures the sort of I don't know the
chaos
right Fourth and
Market good
[Music]
point
where's my
car
is
and this is before or after the trip
there's the camera that same
camera do we know the family we don't
have a name unfortunately this is a
collection that came out of a an estate
sale but nobody recorded where it was
from
I'm going to the San Francisco
International Film Festival the San
Francisco International Film Festival of
course oh so speci I'm coming are you
I'll be
[Applause]
there oh yes fasten your seat
belts
[Applause]
oh my god wow granny
so familiar uh roads and Pathways in
Golden Gate Park today very little
equestrian traffic to right the
prominade
do we love the new
prominade one of the people behind it
Ben Davis is here
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight yeah um any anybody can identify
the band I'm sure you can identify Bella
abzac they marched from downtown to the
band shell and the uh National
Organization for Women requested that
all the cops be women identif women or
in those days they would say women and
uh that caused a bit of a fur I don't
know what ultimately happened but this
is in
1981 uh Pro feminist
audience
somebody asked how we know a film is
from Southern California and you know
it's just from looking at uh the rest of
the films and the preponderance of
evidence and we make some uh some strong
guesses backed up by the image this is
the first Bay Bridge
now known sort of as the dumb
Barton it filled a need
obviously
and some um this is new footage that uh
turned up in a collection that we uh
recently
digitized the hfield and galante
collection and it's a very uh beautiful
collection of film and so I just we
visited this in the past but these are
special
images
[Applause]
the San Francisco
Anchorage
you know the name of that
did anybody see it uh from a better
angle if anybody is a fairy scholar
we've got hours and hours of we would be
very happy to uh make it
available
some of us will remember the trans Bay
terminal these are um ecstatic
commuters
good clothes
though what year was this you know I
couldn't find a date um it's sometime in
the 70s early 70s and it's a film about
the uh the uh intentional Enclave of
Canyon in the Hills near Moraga and I
think they're trying to point out how
unhappy people are who live in the
straight world what do you
think
just a taste this year but here's the
air fairy between Oakland and San
Francisco like a nice smooth ride
there you
go and this is a family from Compton
California coming up to visit relatives
uh on petero Hill you just saw Slovenian
Hall and and finding a nice uh Cliff to
pose
against come on
[Applause]
and then I think we have the reverse
shots you could see what they're looking
at oh she wants to do it too sort
of
meanwhile so this is the Japan China war
um and uh Chinese people in the US are
eagerly a waiting bulletins to um to see
what's going on and this is also the
time when the Chinese community in San
Francisco came out of uh its silence its
public silence which had been a
defensive posture since the uh attempts
to uh shut down Chinatown after the
earthquake and the drug wars and they
collected money they did these um rice
bowl for China parades this is a
newsreel so it's probably dramatized but
the home movie you're going to see in a
minute is not these were so successful
there were several of these that the
city was obliged to think of um Chinese
people in San Francisco as a political
force and for the first time um a
housing project was built the pinyuan uh
project uh there had been no public
housing uh open to to Chinese people at
that time and so this is a key moment uh
not just in uh in anti-war protests but
also in trying to stop uh scrap iron
from going to Japan these are pickets uh
and the long shoreman observed these uh
picket lines and would not load scrap
iron for
Japan it's very rare color footage from
1938 meanwhile PanAm you know went ahead
with the China Clipper uh taking off
from Treasure Island Clipper
Cove
[Music]
Mrs Pitman native of California member
of a Pioneer
Family this was the africanamerican
newal California a college graduate and
a sarathy woman
Mrs Pitman has been a news commentator
on radio for six
years she has a big following in
Northern California particularly in San
Francisco and Oakland who never fail to
tune in her fine
program her program is called The Negro
in the news um here's a beauty contest
you see Miss Hunter's Point Miss
bayew uh these are War workers hold your
hold your
scorn Miss ship
welder yeah but just
wait miss metal
[Applause]
[Music]
burner
[Applause]
and this is the polo field early in the
war um we're not going to focus too much
on World War II but this footage I think
needed to be
seen
one of
those
it's called Force measure where were the
bathrooms the question I always asked
reading children's
[Laughter]
books
you're
World War Guardians of the Golden Gate
headed for the scrap PE big 16-in Coast
artillery defenses at San Francisco made
obsolete by modern aerial and Atomic
Warfare fall before the acet and
tortures of wrecking
Crews last of the fixed Harbor defenses
in the US the 80t long rifles each
weighing 365 tons are on their way back
to the blast furnaces big guns aren't
enough
anymore this is a uh a few shots taken
from a film made in 1948 about a rally
at the West entrance to UC Berkeley if
you want to see what Berkeley students
look like in
1948 it was the Progressive Party a
third party um allied with uh left
Wingers in the Communist Party um a
campaign and the candidate was Henry
Wallace the former agronomist and
secretary of
agriculture um but like many rallies uh
the people are more attending are more
interesting I think than the
speakers this is uh Henry
Wallace and this was the
crowd
and then uh people are signing uh I
don't know if it's Scrolls petitions
whatever but we have a little walk-on
appearance here from Paul
Robison actor and uh uh singer and uh I
guess in those days you would have
called him a peace
worker and this is this is recently
discovered footage about the IH hotel we
don't
know where the filmmaker is um we would
like to find them uh there's a credit in
the the back uh the IH Hotel was um was
a residential hotel where mostly elderly
Filipino men lived and um it was bought
by an investment company named for sees
who evicted or wished to evict everybody
and there was a very very big struggle
aided by many many uh groups in the
community this was the big uh Event in
San Francisco in in
77 um and then finally our leftist
Sheriff evicted everybody at night I'm
not showing you that footage today but
there's some excellent documentaries
about the IH Hotel you can
watch and you know access to cheap
housing uh affordable housing for the
elderly has uh never not been an issue
um and it it was an issue that got a lot
of uh labor support
so when San Francisco is more of a union
town State strike tomorrow will be yes
SF State strike tomorrow
[Applause]
faculty uh this is a truck going down
through the
[Music]
mission
is that the hamburger stand back
there and this is a lovely film that
comes to us through the kindness of
Scott Stark and Bernell Heights thank
you Scott it's a I wish I could show you
the whole thing but instead I've chosen
I've kind of broken it up into
segments it is a process film about a uh
a uh a uh a banquet in
home
maybe somebody will recognize somebody
and we can get their film back to
them uh the the person who gave us this
film is is from Burnell I don't know
where this
is
yeah early
50s
there's a lot of talk these days about
what's wrong with the younger generation
so is on the credit side a group of five
teenagers who have organized their own
Telephone Company put it together from
Surplus and junk equipment into a
smoothly functioning Network that serves
[Music]
subscribers they string wires and
install phones themselves too so far the
service is free the young businessmen
Engineers behind it all have put up the
little cash they needed and the still
growing system already has two exchanges
in Kensington and El Cito think of those
lucky homes with a private wire to
handle those Marathon teenage phone call
there's community service for
you
[Music]
I I don't know and I wish I had a date
the film is not Edge coded and so we're
still working on that I wondered if it
was possibly the portal of Fes
but it's intercut with these beautiful
images of neon and
Chinatown
to6 the Lo is
EMD
really
okay what's
that um he said it had to be post 56
because that locomotive was a something
S7 DM F7 EMD electromotive division of
General Motors F7 we'll look into
that thank
you we refer that to the
re refer it to the research
Department
Le
and this is later we know this is the uh
early to
mid-60s
so I think many of you know about the
Chinese telephone exchange uh every uh
operator knew all the names and numbers
by heart there was a directory which was
a you printed with calligraphy um but
they Ed the switchboard until quite
late
and this is a what's known as a process
plate made to be shown in the background
you'd see it maybe out of a car or out
of a train window it would be projected
out of focus but in reality these are um
these are uh uh very sharp lock down and
we think that these are shell
Mounds uh Native shell mounds and that
this is an inadvertent record of uh of
of white settlement on top of uh sacred
ground um as we approach uh Albany hill
we will see another shell Mound but this
is uh Southern elero and and Northern
Albany
um uh in
a in a period obviously much less
settled probably late
30s thank you were you the person that
noticed that the other year yeah 1939
elero theater that Barn likee
structure thank
you
I think so farms in
Berkeley so we think that this is uh
quite possibly a shell
Mound what is a shell a shell Mound is a
place where uh uh Native people um
performed uh a number of um ceremonies
including internments burials and also
other things were deposited there so
it's a it's a record that is both uh a
day-by-day record and it's also a sacred
record this is a film um by a well I
don't know who actually shot it but this
is a Filipino doctor we don't yet know
his name who worked a number of places
and it's a very striking film just
because of the uh the urban environment
in the late 40s this is sort of the
inner city San Francisco that Philip K
dick writes about in his books um and uh
he stayed at the palace he had some
affiliation we think with Stanford with
Lane hospital later
on May his name Dr
[Laughter]
Pepper
and this is the Glide
Foundation
yes and why are they in City Hall we
wonder if it's a
wedding Civic Center Plaza a little more
attractive the General Motors Motorama
of
53 we've got some of those films
too oh this was this show that went
around the country showing uh the new
cars from General Motors including all
the dream cars the Fantastic science
fictional
cars and this this may be the SCH lock
Factory these are the factories that are
now abandoned down on by Old
Bayshore this is part of the same film
there's SE
Hill and coming into town on Old
Bayshore this is the pre
freeway
world where are we
here and SF General as creepy as always
those
building petero in in
16th the Opera House further to the
[Applause]
right at Mills College in Oakland
California a revolution Ary idea is in
the making students of the new
instruments and composer and designer
Harry parch create weird and unique
music on cloud chamber bowls derived
from Atomic research and a Ki of 72
strings the diamond marima This Modern
Orchestra produces music in 43 tones
instead of the usual
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is one result of part's 30 years of
search for The elusive tones that exist
between the notes on a regular
[Music]
piano
de love you
Mills and here from The Archives of the
San Francisco radio
club are um some of our fellow ham radio
operators at
[Applause]
work
so I'm only able to show you two minutes
of an over 40 minute film um so you'll
just have to imagine or get your
licenses there is a version of it on
YouTube Megan is reminding
me so uh these um folks are doing field
day which is a way of um rehearsing
operations in the the field they this
would be incredibly valuable and a
disaster for example when regular
Communications like cell phones shut
down as they would after a few hours um
and during the war this was the only
amateur operation that was permitted uh
you know civil defense stuff but um what
are amazing I think are these these
panoramas of a partly built
City
yeah it's from Mount
[Applause]
Davidson
this film will soon be up on internet
archive as well for everyone to watch at
length big heavy tube
equipment
this is Burnell
[Music]
Heights
he's a postal
worker and this is the key system rare
color footage the trains in the the
lower deck of the Bay Bridge heading
towards the
city Lower
Deck
cars on the top trucks and trains on the
bottom yes that's
right what year was this I you know I I
couldn't find out I would think it's uh
about 54 55 this is earlier footage
showing the curve um either into were
out of the trans Bay terminal which was
served by trains before
buses
[Music]
everywhere the Golden Gate City figures
out an upto-date way to send its
greetings to the World by way of the sky
in letters 10 ft High a new idea that's
just as bright and cheerful as San
Francisco itself the auto gyro piloted
by Captain Claude Owen and the captains
taking an awful chance in that crowd of
buildings one little slip and the
greetings will turn into something not
quite so cheerful he's aiming from a
beautiful Civic sent and he's only got a
space to land in 125 ft by 300 to the
trolley line at the upper Amazon
delivery Captain knows his Stu and for
the first time in history a plane lands
on San Francisco's front porch well it's
a nice thought San Francisco and the
same to you and many others oh my
God
our neighbors from the Richmond
District Kathy G who uh gave us this
film for
scanning we're up on Miraloma not far
from the Tower Market um I couldn't
resist paying a little bit of homage to
film projectionists
here
and this is when you can shift in your
seats and get ready for the last few
minutes the carbon arcs they still uh at
the Stanford theater and paloalto they
still show films this
way and where at the Roxy Roy awesome
okay the Roxy also does
35mm uh projector workshops if you'd
like to start to learn that
trade
what's the carbon
art it's how they get the light that's
bright enough to
project
creting you create a High
[Music]
Vol San Francisco a city so beautiful
her worshippers hop she would never
change faces a drastic face liting for
even the guardian of the Golden Gate has
been rocked by America's population
explosion some traditions like the
Beloved old cable cars are jealously
preserved even though mass
transportation is desperately
needed Chinatown to the largest Chinese
settlement outside the orian refuses to
lose its exotic though neighborly
character lormes will fight for
Fisherman's Warf to the last drop of
lobster sauce yet the brutal fact is
that the lovely old city is bursting at
the seams the the old must give way to
the new San franciscans hope that it is
the worst of the old that goes and that
the new is worthy of the tradition of
inherits to that end a daring master
plan has been inaugurated which includes
replacing the wholesale produce market
area with a modern complex of apartment
houses and Office Buildings California
has just become the most populous state
in the Union and a large segment of the
new population has been drawn to San
Francisco and to Los Angeles in the
south
[Music]
the urban renewal plan under which the
substandard dwellings are to be replaced
by modern housing and business centers
poses problems beyond the M billion fin
removal of vast numbers of people to lwi
income residential developments could
fill up the Open Spaces that make the 6
County Bay Area so attractive it could
strain educational police and municipal
government facilities but as she Rose
From the Ashes of her great earthquake
San Francisco can rise literally in the
upward thrust of soaring Towers to take
care of the thousands who keep coming on
to live beside the Golden
[Music]
Gate built on a magic word
accessibility but the real magic comes
with new people to provide labor for the
industries who themselves create new
markets people like Mary and John and
their new babies
whose new home may be only a torn up
Hillside as they see it now but which
soon will materialize to them and to
hundreds of thousands of other new
Californians as realities homes of
building at a cost they can afford in
areas where they choose to
live
yes
[Music]
homes for all incomes new original
architecturally exciting building as
swiftly as the land is
[Music]
building Hydro foil roll out on Lake
Meritt
this didn't catch
on all right watch
[Music]
closely yeah this was um this was SFO
helicopter uh which served the airports
um also decided to get into Hydro foils
this is our friend fog and this is some
Richman District sites a
uh uh a rockan mom or Aunt or
friend and also a Richmond District
Hound
he's a good boy if that uh if that
backyard and those uh posts holding up
the sun room look familiar than you live
in the
Avenues out
[Applause]
this could be Jane the bakery you know
it's where
they
this is footage that we were recently uh
uh lent and it's um it's uh well the
portal the green houses there were quite
a number of them there's been a film
about by uh Caitlyn Galloway and another
about um trying to save some of them
this was still active in the
70s and um
uh some you know beautifully
engineered this footage is from
1976 what did they grow this was the day
before they were torn
down yes are you the person who shot
that that's me yeah thank you so
[Applause]
much
no well just
wait recycling some of the windows the
day before it's torn
down this is was it 76 actually summer
of 75 summer of 75 thank
you
so this is
a wonderful example of mixed
use we didn't have the time for labor to
recycle all the windows we got as many
as we could in one
Dayo why did they take them
out
houses
and his
son
developed housing on the on the
[Music]
L it's really a monster movie in so many
ways I can move
[Laughter]
right
in
used to build small green
houses one of which was at
the Institute place near
o I think we're at Fort Mason here a
wonderful biring
site and a recently
rediscovered uh beautiful trova footage
of the 78 parade this was the year that
the rainbow flag was first uh shown I'm
told please call out anything you
recognize
anybody
[Applause]
am
anybody want to explain the uh the the
Briggs
decision outw gay te right it was an
attack on uh lesbian and gay people who
were
teaching on stde November 78 defeated
lost
[Applause]
[Music]
wonderful wasn't full of
[Applause]
St
it did not have sound I wish it
did
this was milk's last
parade yes that's
right
spor I know isn't that
striking no bottled water no Jeff blue
no honest gay images in film anybody
recognize
[Applause]
and the
stud
the
float soon to reopen we
[Applause]
help
yes yes dkes on bikes we just saw
and now we're going to conclude with the
world's fastest trip to the
beach caret
theater second
French hospital Star of the
Sea Park
predio Alexandria sight of caspari's
pizza coming
up this was before the Pacific
[Music]
Cafe
[Applause]
wo
w
[Applause]
wooo
these are the people who made this all
[Applause]
[Music]
possible
[Applause]
[Music]
John Carlson uh worked in Monaco labs
and has uh dearly dearly missed he was a
teacher a filmmaker a consumate
technician and much of the footage in
here comes from his collection and we
thank his
family and we thank all of
you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for coming live
[Applause]
stream thank
you
[Music]